[Music]
hey how are you how you having a good
summer so far yes so many penises okay
it's summer so let's talk about that
what do you mean so I mean okay I'm just
ask you I'm gonna go there so many
penises what's happening uh let me
explain okay I was a bachelorette I was
a maid of honor at a bachelorette party
last weekend in Delaware oh and like I
said there was just penises everywhere
okay
why were there penises everywhere
because it was my job to provide the
party stuff so I the party favors yeah
the favors activities so and I've never
done that before so I I kind of went
crazy and I sent in a huge box of just
penis paraphernalia to my mom's house
well you're talking about okay
fake penises it's anything you can
imagine like I can imagine a lot the
same thing yeah lollipops hats necklaces
a very realistic cake that we actually
couldn't show on your show I think
because it was a gross it was gnarly
yeah so just all kinds of like yeah like
a shield squeegee I just sent it all to
my mom's house and she actually thought
she was opening my sister's school
uniform no she's right yeah she really
sorry and I'm a so she was getting your
your sister wears a uniform at school
yes she goes to the Catholic school Oh
God mom open the box and it was just
like what did she say she must have been
really upset she loved it
okay did you hire like its traditional
if the party's getting a little raunchy
sometimes to hire a male stripper for
the we didn't actually but funny thing
you asked at 3:30 in the morning
some want one of the bridesmaids
drunkenly went on the street and just
asked these two random guys to pretend
to be strippers and come to our house
party and because it was Dewey Beach
which is in Delaware and anything goes
there I think these two guys were just
like yeah it's the least shocking thing
you said so wait wait they went in and
they found strangers on the stress two
dudes who throws and they were so down
and they took their clothes off and came
in the house and pretended to be
strippers and the the bride-to-be
actually thought they were a real
servers because they were strangers and
she would pretend who would who would
pretend these guys I don't know what
their names were stick around for the
purpose that gets a little tight that's
a little dicey to have two strange men
come in to a party and take off their
clothes I left very I left right away
right but within the hour yeah yeah yeah
it got a little weird
but I think everyone had a good time
that's cool yeah yeah what sounds like
fun I guess yeah did you pay these guys
I'm curious if these guys get paid oh
yeah they well let's just say they got
what was coming to them
you